[Applause]
wait what are we looking at here it's a
cat sitting on glass and we're
underneath it it's pretty good oh it's
spectacular there's something in the DNA
of cats that allows them to look
effortlessly luxurious wherever they are
some people say they're kind of like a
liquid I think they're more like sand
like three bags of sand some people look
at cats interacting with glass and
they're like what could how stupid this
cat looks it doesn't get it it doesn't
know that it can't penetrate this thing
I think cats have a deeper understanding
of glass and we give them credit for it
it's really using the glass to its full
potential yeah it's just pushing itself
against it you know when cats bring you
like a dead animal yeah they're trying
to like teach how to hunt yeah I think
that's what they're doing here I think
they're teaching us like how to be
comfortable with our bodies or something
the tragedies that you can't know what
it feels like no not really
this one looks like it's set and
strawberry yogurt yeah I think cats like
that you can't touch them through the
glass they're presenting this great
thing that they have and they're
withholding it it's kind of like in
science museums when they cut a car in
half or a computer or something and you
get to see that cross-section of what's
inside now we know what's inside of cats
yeah it's just more cat you know that
feeling you get when you see a really
cute cat you just want to squeeze it
really I think what cats look like on
glass is the physical embodiment of that
feeling I don't get that feeling clearly
you don't love cats enough
[Music]